hello and welcome to this video playing
Justin Yano five six five really like to
know the name it I have to adjust a
number just figured it out that the
number is wrong okay I get my standard
line against the English the improve cop
often is called now hoping for castles
age five which is always leading to
entertaining play and probably good for
black with this person international
master okay but not a name in there yeah
black is already fighting for advantage
after age five however the positions are
so so complicated I had a game against
him that I lost don't remember
they are so complicated that you
sometimes really screw up even great
positions yeah add this on the board
really often
isn't that the weirdest position ever
absolutely I think this is the weirdest
position ever I wouldn't be happy with
white really not I know I'm criticizing
people for playing quickly but I had
this on the board in earlier games so
just developing should be okay the
tricky thing is white does not want to
move any of his points him he doesn't
want to play d5 and open up my bishop
behind us it's also not very desirable
how do you play though with black rook
e8 maybe it looks kind of normal
preventing B should be - yeah I got
Knight to B form doesn't really do much
I would love to have a bishop on g6 but
this is probably one of those
things that never going to happen but in
locked position reigning queen going to
g6 would also be nice poor
my ideas Queenie 7f 76
actually that's not good I did not I did
not really register that that I don't
have night before now
case or 96 and that what is doing on g6
not much
if he moves the night have Bishop to b5
and my ideas to play the knight to f6
and put a bit more pressure on the pawn
and maybe again Bishop over to g6 or to
f7 is Knight f6 kind of useful maybe he
wants to sec the exchange interesting
but okay this is this is good anyway
well he good I mean it's a useful way to
as useful move okay he just want to
check sexy Shh
check the exchange I'm sorry yeah I
can't I can always take it if I want but
he will he will get some conversation
for sure this move intense Bishop f5 and
trying to win the D pawn just being very
but very subtle about it okay so now I'm
close to Bishop g6 or Bishop f7 for that
matter he had on yet Queen to a5 maybe
just recognize that ouch
but I have many pieces if I take only
one check I'm not really not sure about
it he has the smooth g5 which is
disturbing form twin to f5 is the thing
we should be five Queen f5 that gives
his I'm probably losing which is a bit
of a shame regarding I mean this was
definitely good for black that's not
really something I am willing to to
doubt but but I I lost control down yeah
yeah that that I lost control over this
position nine takes g5 yeah that is said
something like that I missed
like somebody here white I think it's
not in good shape
I would be surprised when he has a
completely dead piece there for example
and I don't believe it
yeah super complicated this is this is
something where you really have no clue
what's going on it's just so complicated
in a weird and by the way here you don't
have to play this but I feel it's just
too too funny to not play it somehow
maybe in a tournament game a classical
time control game I would play
differently the engine doesn't like my
position all that much yeah it always
wants to go nighty for here yeah but
edge I want to mostly learn if I can
play better roughly here because justice
I don't believe you should have for
maybe I can maybe sacrifice
if it can't play that move it's going to
be dangerous because now there's a
potential f4 later should hear a clunky
tool very odd engine says roughly along
don't know what's going on there yeah I
was really happy with this maneuvers you
know that that's what makes it a bit of
a shame for me because I felt I played
it okay improving pieces and so on and I
also like this but should be six idea
and the engine just wants to take him
yeah I thought this could be something I
didn't think it is enough but I didn't
feel I should take simply but this is a
good move that is a really good move
that stops e5 subway because here the
pieces get active and that's no
compensation
okay so that was refuting the idea I
just wanted to to play for one for this
for this upon okay Knight takes before I
have to do this then yeah here the
problem is I have I don't have enough
coordination not here material bytes of
course black is fine but it just no I
have no my pieces don't play together
and I will lose one of them and then the
game is totally over g5 year Queen to f5
is the thing and you cannot hold it
to
they spotted 95 that was a good one
yeah I should play Bishop d7 right okay
this is just just bad just bad position
for nothing I'm a little bit
Ruby sixes funny move just Queen d2 us
is good of course but this is a cool
move if it works it and if the engine
gets +3 it does work it's nice right in
in Queen f5 so let's see I keep it
let's say I keep it only goes here
Bishop d3 ok that attack is pretty
strong ok thanks for watching